We had three requirements for
a trusted computing base.
Isolation or tamper-proof was
one of those requirements.
And we've been talking about
isolation and memory protection.
All that is done to get that
tamper-proof requirement.
Untrusted code cannot be altering
the operating system data and code.
So that was all to do with meeting
one of those requirements,
which is tamper-proof.
The other requirement is complete
mediation, that you should not be able
to bypass the operating system and
go directly to a protected resource.
So how do we implement
complete mediation?
Well, the way we do that is we make
sure that no protected resource,
whether it's a memory page or a file,
could be accessed without going through
the trusted computing base or
the kernel.
Okay, so the TCB is also the kernel.
The way we do that is by making
the trusted computing base,
or having it act as a reference monitor.
Any time you have a reference for
a particular resource, the TCB
has to come into the picture before
you can get to the resource, okay.
The reference has to be monitored
by the trusted computing base.
So there should be no way for
you to bypass,
where one way you can get around
complete mediation is by that bypassing
the trusted computing base, there should
be no way for you to bypass this.
So how is that implemented?